Michelle Turner the ama fashions oh my
good oh my goodness oh my goodness is
definitely right they were walking on
the edge last night Kevin just take a
look at mama team
Chrissy Teigen gets out how did she get
away with that award with her dress lit
up to her armpit and a cutout back from
every angle Chrissy was a malfunction
waiting to happen
those two gold safety pins win hardest
working accessories of the night Best
Dressed baby bump goes to Sierra this
dress was like so amazing on a girl with
no belly so I was kind of like how is
this gonna go with the big booth and
hopefully my bump is not too big for and
stretching right yes it is yeah do you
know if it's a boy or girl yeah I do
know are you telling I lied
tell me about your son is he excited to
be a big brother he is he rubs my belly
and he says hi baby I love you baby I
can't wait to meet you baby and then he
puts my shirt guy says bye my baby's
best body just two months after baby
that be mrs. Adam Levine BRE Prinsloo
and best legs on display well that's a
tie between Nina Dobrev and Julianne
Hough
tell me about wedding planning how do
you set a date picked a dress any of
that stuff I have not picked to drive
but we definitely set a date so that's a
good that's step one right so that's
good
peekaboo looks and pants were on trend
on the red carpet the five outfits and
one night winner is AMA co-host
Gigi Hadid red carpet it was white off
the shoulder Lakes then on stage she
changed four times our faith that's
smokin hot one-shouldered red Versace
the dress that left us scratching our
heads was Olivia Munn's Reem Acra and
taraji P Henson gets honors for the
sexiest way to use a white shirt my
stylist J from look like we want to try
this effortless looks like you just got
out of the bed with your boyfriend I was
like okay and they put the hair that is
I mean like listen let me tell you
something if you get out of bed like
looking like this now I'm not one to
gossip but just so everyone knows Camryn
has a little crush on taraji Phil my
best dressed of the night was Lady Gaga
in white Brandon Maxwell look at that
suit tailored to perfection and the Hat
oh god guys everything
you